hey how's it going my name's Peter this
is not a dildo it's a it's a microphone
stop it how would you how would you even
fit do you know what just it's not funny
summer's over it's time to get back to
school get back to work get back to
murdering your family and whatever
you're doing you need to look good while
doing it and we all know you're not the
most photogenic type how did I know that
don't question it
I get asked every day every hour every
minute how do you look so fabulous and
well I'm gonna show you my secret so we
are gonna start by taking a picture yes
I have ears
I know it's pretty amazing as you can
see this is pretty revolting I mean
where's the headphones I know a lot of
you bros are probably a little skeptic
into wearing makeup and it's nothing to
be ashamed of because everyone wears
makeup oh we can select hair wow that
sure looks great have you ever had such
amazing hair that it goes outside the
picture well I had oh my god I'm
beautiful look at that ladies ladies Oh
shocked yard shocked yard oh my god
shucks yard okay let's go through it
that's pretty cute ohh oh my god that's
cute that's cute
how do say after me sake art that you're
not doing it right
repeat after me sir he ah'd all right
you're never gonna learn oh my god well
I can't even make the hair like do weird
things oh my god the future is here my
hair is like a monster just waiting to
eat someone's face all right we done the
hair let's work on the face I guess I'm
a natural beauty because I don't see a
difference concealer yeah we need that
conceal don't feel don't let him know
suck yacht that's great let's use that
one
alright let's go for the lips I want
some lipstick this is awkward
I feel like this is awkward what am I
doing here why am I doing this again I
look really good like I can't help
looking this good it's not my fault I am
strangely aroused right now lip liner I
didn't even know that was a thing bow
science man oh my god suck hot [ __ ] I
look [ __ ] fab as [ __ ] me haters like
you're so [ __ ] jealous right now look
at this see I barely need any touch-up
effects at all to look this good
whoops what happened no hair what are
you doing hair don't eat my face come on
goddamn it
what's extras was this the [ __ ] is this
hey am i beautiful tell me I'm beautiful
tell me
all right let's finalize like who thinks
this looks good I'm not gonna pay for
your ugly ass filters I am all natural
all right I don't need no stupid filters
to make me look pretty now I can post
this hashtag note oh my god I'm [ __ ]
fat man save that [ __ ] what does mean
there we go
very nice what are the stickers I want
people to think I'm smart yes
all right now we're almost done but we
have one more to try okay that does not
look terrifying at all oh my god why not
have a haircut on your haircut haircut
ception I just want the [ __ ] tiara
and we're finished you will look amazing
on this picture with these simple steps
this is how you were fabulous so if
you're a guy or a girl who does this you
might not want to show anyone this
because it's [ __ ] embarrassing all
right I'm gonna check it to see what you
bros thinking out this hardly any makeup
hashtag no filter there's no reason to
lie
we got fabulous fab fab Queen C we only
have great compliments here I can tell
they're all very serious - oh my god so
pretty I want to be like you my picture
may not be straight but at least this
person has
their priorities straight oh the natural
look is amazing on you you should go no
filter oh my god
alright this is a really stupid thing I
don't even know if you are watching
thank you for leaving a like I really
appreciate it it helps me out a lot and
thanks for hanging out with me today and
doing weird [ __ ] I'll leave a link to
the app if you want to try this scepters
don't do it
and as always stay awesome friends bro